buenos días sergei petukov usted ocupa
cargos públicos fue viceministro de
justicia en su país en ucrania y también
es profesor de derecho internacional es
buenos días y gracias por estar con
nosotras
buenas dietas de khyber
la primera pregunta que quisiera hacerla
es sobre la corte penal internacional
que está analizando si hubo crímenes de
guerra en ucrania usted cree que es
posible probar estos crímenes de guerra
estoy seguro que eso es que lo va a
pasar que corte internacional va a hacer
una investigación y junto con las
autoridades y nos iba a establecer todos
los pactos y
[Música]
en ucrania y todos los crímenes que han
cometido los rusos porque a este momento
no
hacen todo lo que quieren y están
están
atacando a
los civiles a las ciudades y en este y
en nuestro tiempo todos tienen un
smartphone y pueden grabar a todo lo que
pasa y por eso hay muchas muchas
evidencias de sus crímenes por eso estoy
seguro que les será posible
a hacer un proceso
internacional y establecer todos los a
todos los crímenes que estamos estamos
de qué estamos
hemos visto pasando en ucrania y eso es
muy importante porque la propaganda rusa
dice que no hace nada de eso dicen que
solamente están atacando a los los
militares y eso no es verdad y me
imagino que es evidente por todo el
mundo porque hay muchos los realistas
presentes en ucrania y también la gente
que no tienen
tienen teléfonos para robarlo y por eso
debemos muchas muchas informaciones
muchos vídeos muchos testigos de
suscriben esta guerra
qué qué casos usted ha identificado que
podrían resultar
crímenes de guerra de los que hemos
incurrido en las últimas semanas
bueno me imagino que el caso
más famoso es un ataque sobre el
hospital de maternidad en marín por
y que fue grabado por todas cosas
canales internacionales pero hay mucho
mucho más porque en cada día están
atacando las ciudades como jarquín
football league y ahora que la capital
y mueren
los habitantes y que hay
en esos todos esos ataques
no hay objetivos militares para hacerlo
entonces atacan a los cursos ataquen a
los hospitales a los civiles a los
barrios de las ciudades a las escuelas
universidades todos estos son objetivos
civiles que no podrían ser atacados en
la guerra entonces
vamos todos esos casos y son ya no es un
caso único es una práctica normal para
las fuerzas armadas rusas
las negociaciones para el proceso de paz
parecen estar en un punto muerto usted
qué opina de la posibilidad de que
ucrania adopte un estatus de neutralidad
bueno
eso en verdad no es cuestión del estado
es neutralidad per se porque el problema
es que iba a garantizar que vamos a
permanecer como un estado independiente
porque a este momento este es claro para
todos en ucrania y todo el mundo que no
se puede creer a los rusos que el
presidente ejecutivo a cambiar su
posición en algún momento y por eso y si
no debemos a
garantías de otros de otros países no
podemos hacer ningún acuerdo con los
rusos y no importa qué tiene ese
documento neutralidad de militarización
otras cosas no no se crían a los usos
por eso no es un problema que vamos a
qué vamos a hacer y qué vamos a enseñar
en ese documento pero el problema único
es que va a garantizar porque no se
crean los usos cuáles podrían ser esos
países que dan estas garantías
bueno esos son los países de europa
turquía eeuu y otros que tienen una
potencia militar para proteger un cráneo
en caso que usa rompe todo todos los
acuerdos que ha pasado ahora y también
en 2014 cuando la luz se anexionó el
crimen y un partido de dos más parte de
este de mi país
en su opinión cuál sería un compromiso
entre las peticiones de rusia y las de
ucrania realista y aceptable también
para su país
ahora es imposible a decir porque las
posiciones de ucranianos y rusos son muy
diferentes los rusos y presidente
también dice que en verdad no hay una
nación ucraniana no existen somos un
único país único en la única nación y
que quiere restablecer una unión
soviética eso no es una cosa que ésta es
aceptable para los ucranianos porque ha
en unión soviética no hay un futuro para
ucrania no hay un futuro para nación
para cultura para idioma por eso es muy
muy difícil a decir que vamos a tener un
acuerdo en este momento no imagino que
rusia tiene que cambiar su posición
y muchas cosas dependen de la situación
militar en el país en este momento
el blitz creek una guerra muy rápida que
quiero si allá no existe no hay están en
un punto muerto porque no saben qué
hacer más porque no cambian las
posiciones de sus armas por eso me
imagino que vamos a tener no una acuerdo
de paz pero algún tipo de acuerdo de
tres cómo decirlo en español y eso eso
sí y pues el problema es que no es sólo
para solamente una una guerra contra
entre rusia y ucrania es una guerra de
rusia de putin por por por la red de
brisa viento de la unión soviética y sus
zonas de influencia por eso
es difícil hacer un acuerdo entre los
países porque pueden también tiene
muchas cosas para europa y eeuu
cómo a cambiar la cuerda del nado otan
otan en español
sí y otras cosas neutralidad de otros
países como por ejemplo a suecia y
finlandia
y por eso hay ningún acuerdo entre
ucraniano
cerrar esa situación con renuncia por
eso es muy difícil y me imagino que
vamos a tener un acuerdo
aún es ninguna cuerda una declaración de
un disparo
alto al fuego
no me queda claro si usted cree que nos
encontramos en el comienzo en la mitad o
en el final de la guerra
estamos en la mitad de la guerra y para
eso ya hemos visto en desde 2014 cuando
se anexiona crimea en lomas todos esos 8
años teníamos un conflicto una guerra en
dogmas y morían la gente casi cada
estimada y bueno había una fase muy muy
activa de la guerra en años
2014-2015 pues era una situación de un
conflicto de bajo nivel y me imagino que
una cosa así va a pasar en la escala más
grande por todo el país todo cráneo y da
miedo rusia belarús y quizás otros
puentes eso es difícil decir porque sólo
pueden que a este momento decida que va
a atacar a la próxima semana no sé por
cuánto tiempo cree usted que puede
seguir esta
al total en el país
bueno
yo soy un poco pesimista
pero pero vamos a ver
lo que importante es que los ucranianos
estamos juntos y preparados tenemos
este s
entendemos que es una es una guerra por
por
nuestro país que si no vamos a pelear y
continuar no vamos a existir por eso me
imagino es lo que bernanke lobo creado
son
estamos juntos y vamos a continuar hasta
que podemos a vivir en nuestro país
independiente cuánto tiempo va a pasar
eso no eso no son eso es difícil es
decir esto es una es una visión para
rusia y para repetir también una
decisión de cuánto tiempo va a
permanecer y va a continuar su economía
de rusia sobre esas acciones que van a
pesar más de más a la
colonia rusa pero también me imagino que
que a un momento a la población rusa va
a entender que algunas cosas no
funcionaban no funcionan como como
querían y van a preguntar a su gobierno
porque hay todos muertos porque hay
muchas muchas
muertos de fuerzas armadas rusas
no tan bien
de que no sabían antes porque rusia
ahora no nos dice nada no nos dice nada
sobre lo que pasa en ucrania en verdad y
cuánto 24 muertes tienen fuerzas armadas
por eso me imagino que la guerra en
ucrania va a cambiar va a cambiar en su
intensidad
pero también
pudimos hacer otras cosas y atacar con
otras armas y quizás en otras partes de
ucrania y también a va a hacer una
guerra diplomática y guerra de
información y así que es importante que
quedamos unidos todos nosotros coordinar
con coordinación contra el putin
muchísimas gracias
sergei p tu software visión ex
viceministro de justicia de ucrania y
profesor de derecho internacional
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
gracias por su atención
[Música]